[Music]
everyone what's the procedure ah I
realized documentary crews are not
supposed to insert themselves into what
they're filming but the camera person's
life is potentially in danger here as
well and he or she knows what Dwight did
so the idea that they wouldn't let
someone in on this is a bit ludicrous
speedin for this show how many ways are
there to get in and out of this office
there is no fire it was only a
simulation except there was a fire in a
trash can with accelerant that you
walked away from and I just never
mentioned again even though no one put
it out so simulate this [ __ ] how
could you possibly think this is a good
idea nope there is no way they even let
Dwight back in the building and this is
not how this conversation goes the
actual conversation is two words long
your fire it even has the added bonus of
including fire based wordplay nobody
should have to go to work thinking oh
this is the place that I might die today
you would think so but who will speak
for the economy office is for not dying
that's funny I thought the office was
for often mistakenly thinking that
Corinne genus is the same thing as
hilarious
look I don't usually go all fashion sins
and such but these three shirts seem
like a bit of fashion overkill to me do
you really need the turtleneck button-up
and sweater vest eliminate any one
article of clothing and everything
immediately gets better much like life
in general what are you gonna do if
you're by yourself and your heart stops
it's Michael really suggesting self CPR
here of all the versions of Michael I
prefer the so dumb how does even feed
himself version the least you know what
if we come across somebody with no arms
or legs do we bother resuscitating them
if I remember my elementary school
education you need to find out what
their name is for instance if they're on
the floor their name is most likely Matt
now onto the work of determining what
actually is grosser than gross okay too
fast I would think the bigger issue is
that Michael is doing his compressions
on the neck versus the chest I didn't
think it was very realistic in the movie
and it turns out it's pretty realistic
cinemasins research and now Dwight knows
not to cut the face off a real person
I'm only gonna say this once more and
then add a bunch of sins but when you
make your characters dumb in a way that
is beyond recognizable as human you
dismantle any chance I have of
connecting to them and short-circuit the
humors foundation in any kind of truth
it's the Homer effect that it's costing
you 20 sins in this episode
Jim misses Hannah day please call me
Lily I can't tell if this fake move in
with Jack black Jessica Alba and Cloris
Leachman is supposed to be funny and
failing or be so mundane it's supposed
to make this episode feel more exciting
in comparison either way sorry but you
didn't realize she was in the bathroom
right be thankful taking a bath is what
you got and since I'm sending a movie
within a TV show I'm pretty sure the
recursive sitting principles of the
Metta hypothesis kicks in and increases
the sin tenfold
that's just science castle distance
where did you think his voice was coming
from and why exactly is she so put off
by his pants of course common is
exaggerated reactions for humor sake
doesn't make it any less of a sin that's
what he said right guys cuz of gay I
don't even I mean so it wasn't white
after all looks like I am the killer
Michael she wrote 50% of marriages end
in divorce nope though it is difficult
to truly measure many studies show that
the divorce rate is about 40% for
marriages 35 years ago and going down
significantly every year parently about
85% of the marriages since the year 2000
are still together my point is this is
another one of those statistics that
gets thrown around all the time like
it's true and I'm disappointed our man
Jim doesn't know better what could Jim
have said to make my dad want to leave
my mom I get this is a very special
Super Bowl episode but god damn it could
they not have come up with something
more interesting than a marriage
separation subplot to force us towards
the inevitable Jim and Pam
smoochy-smoochy do you really want us to
roast you that's offensive conversations
with office fans I consider myself a
good person but I'm gonna try to make
him cry sending Michael Bay movies I've
got to make sure that YouTube comes down
to tape this this was a joke in 2009
since YouTube didn't make content but
then later they did and that also was a
joke
and it's never wise to send the hand
that feeds you but here we are if this
is all happening in the same day does
Michael just have a blown-up photo of
himself for pop events such as this I
mean he probably does but that doesn't
make it any less weird or sinful on him
naked shouldn't the joke here be the
iPod mini sure the shuffle was
technically smaller but with mini the
slam is right there in the name so that
years later when no one remembers what
the shuffle was they are wondering
my Pam is talking about Michael's junk
shuffling around you got a plan ahead
with this stuff BAM also if Pam has this
zinger loaded up in the chamber why does
she leave the stage before firing it
[Music]
attempting a song parody when your name
is at Weird Al Yankovic also being the
most obnoxious character on this show
takes a lot of talent so I guess Ted
Helms is the century's Marlon Brando
[Applause]
good for Dwight but all Phyllis has to
do is report him for mail fraud and
pretty sure that will be his third
strike with the company and they would
have no choice but to let him go
[Music]
dear god this movie within a show is so
actively mediocre it negates its own
existence it's not good enough to be
interesting and not bad enough to be
funny I even go through all the effort
to film it for this episode it's like
wanting toast and then driving a
Nebraska to harvest your own grain you
say wasn't my fault yeah he said that
you told him how much you loved me I
know I made the scene earlier about this
subplot but goddamn it this is a great
moment for these two characters and
Krasinski and Fisher pull it off so
beautifully take us in off you bastard
I'm not crying you're crying when you're
a kid you assume your parents are soul
mates my kids are gonna be right about
that naivete they say that laughter is
the best medicine so Stanley you can
throw away those pills
Scientology boom roasted
I love Timmy
Simmons is all make sure you click that
Bell icon but clicking the little bell
icon is how you make sure you get
notified every time we release a video
so click it
dogs and cats living together masses
pareo these muffins taste bad
these tips are good ok you know what
that could be a little confusing because
in sales
ABC means always be closing a b c always
be closing
no rows they are not breathing and they
have no arms or legs you ever see 127
hours spoiler alert
looks like I am the killer I'd like to
speak to my lawyer may have your
attention please sign in sign in on the
sign-in sheet what is that what is it
like a bakery you pick your pick a
number Tommy that's a big thing I I just
had some thoughts that I wanted to share
with you people what do you mean you
people